[Música]
miles de personas esperan en la sitiada
ciudad de mariupol por la apertura del
corredor humanitario prometido por rusia
alrededor de 160.000 civiles buscan huir
organismos humanitarios buscan ingresar
con ayudas
en francia saltó la polémica en torno a
la campaña electoral del presidente
manuel macro por el amplio uso que el
gobierno hace de consultoras externas
para aplicar políticas públicas destaca
la contratación de la estadounidense
mckinsey acusada de no pagar impuestos
en francia en los últimos diez años
en el salvador entraron en vigor las
reformas legales para endurecer las
penas contra las pandillas por el
aumento de homicidios entretanto méxico
guatemala y honduras han reforzado sus
controles fronterizos porque temen que
los pandilleros huyan hacia su
territorio tenemos reporte de nuestro
corresponsal en centroamérica
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos con un repaso a
la actualidad de la guerra en ucrania
este jueves el ministerio de defensa
ruso anunció un alto al fuego en la
ciudad de mariupol con el fin de abrir
un corredor humanitario hacia zamorilla
a partir de este viernes primero de
abril entretanto los soldados rusos se
retiraron de la central nuclear de
chernóbil pero persisten los ataques
sobre ciudades como mick life chernigov
o quiere lo que despierta los recelos de
la otan sobre el repliegue anunciado por
el ejército ruso en el donbass veamos
más en el siguiente informe de marina
sardenya
a medida que las fuerzas ucranianas
recuperan posiciones los cuerpos de los
civiles son rescatados de las ruinas y
los supervivientes atrapados durante
días entre los combates y la artillería
rusa son evacuados de sus resguardos
como esta residente de ir pink miss
murió en la capital y expertos estoy
estado
de lo más aterrador es que no había agua
comida ni luz siempre decía que si había
luz sobre vivíamos pero no había
pero el fuego cruzado continúa en otras
partes del país cuando se cumplen 36
días de guerra el mariupol moscú y kiev
acordaron un cese el fuego desde la
medianoche del jueves para garantizar
con un corredor humanitario la entrada
de suministros y la salida de los
civiles pese a las promesas la ciudad
portuaria todavía está sitiada con más
de 160 mil personas atrapadas en las
localidades aledañas ciento se apresuran
a abandonar el resto de sus hogares
según kiev casi 1.500 civiles han sido
evacuados de puntos conflictivos en las
últimas 24 horas cuando carl de un cada
puesto de control los hombres serán
desnudados
cada 30 metros hay un control ruso todos
los hombres son desnuda dos buscan
tatuajes después de los controles
seguimos avanzando aldo mújica reside en
su discurso nocturno el mandatario
ucraniano dijo que las tropas rusas
habían abandonado la planta de energía
nuclear de chernóbil pero reiteró que el
kremlin sigue atacando otras
estratégicas posiciones con abdón base
en done base mariupol y en dirección a
jarque las fuerzas rusas están
acumulando recursos para poderosos
ataques
pudimos nos defenderemos haremos todo lo
posible para detener a los ocupantes y
limpiar nuestro territorio de sus
crímenes malvados y sin sentido
las autoridades ucranianas también
denunciaron que desde el inicio de la
guerra las fuerzas rusas mataron a 148
niños en bombardeos y ataques aéreos lo
que constituiría un crimen de guerra
cambiamos de tema y volvemos la mirada a
francia porque a 10 días de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
el escándalo mckinsey es una piedra en
el zapato para el presidente manuel
macro el mandatario y candidato ha
gastado millones de euros en contratos
con la consultora estadounidense veamos
a continuación de qué se trata esta
polémica podría definirse como una
respuesta para el control de daños el
miércoles 30 de marzo dos ministros del
gabinete francés ofrecieron una rueda de
prensa para defender las acusaciones de
gasto excesivo y de socavar el sistema
de funcionarios públicos según un
informe del senado el gobierno del
presidente francés emmanuel macrón gastó
casi mil millones de euros el año pasado
en consultoras entre ellas la firma
estadounidense mckinsey and code un
gasto que se duplicó con creces entre
2018 y 2021 pero ante las que el
gobierno se defiende de quienes lo
acusan de adicción al gasto y willow
gobernando así un pleno si el gobierno
acepta plenamente que en estas
circunstancias excepcionales ha tenido
que recurrir a refuerzos más allá de la
indispensable continuidad de los
servicios públicos de la gestión 24/7 de
kobe 19 y de estas consecuencias
económicas y sociales aceptamos también
que había que transformar nuestro país
para obtener los resultados lo más
rápidamente posible al servicio de los
franceses rioja como posible
cuestión que se destaca en el informe y
que está siendo utilizada como munición
por los rivales de macrón tanto en la
izquierda como la derecha son los
asuntos fiscales de mckinsey ya que no
ha pagado el impuesto de sociedades
entre 2011 y 2020 algo a lo que los
ministros se apresuraron a responder de
usted de un partido de fútbol y société
el impago de impuestos de sociedades no
está vinculado sistemáticamente a
elevación o al fraude deliberado no se
pagan impuestos de sociedades cuando no
se obtienen beneficios es crucial y
cipayos beneficio el asunto mckean si
preocupa a los partidarios de macrón
mientras que algunos quieren
contraatacar diciendo que todas las
administraciones extranjeras recurren a
consultoras globales como lo han hecho
anteriores gobiernos franceses otros
tienen que el caso y adiciones más leña
al fuego a los rivales de la campaña a
tan sólo diez días para que comience la
primera vuelta de las elecciones y en el
salvador este jueves entraron en vigor
las reformas legales para endurecer las
penas contra las pandillas estas medidas
fueron aprobadas sin discusión
parlamentaria y reformar el código penal
en medio de un estado de excepción
dictado por el congreso a petición del
presidente en allí bukele por el aumento
de los homicidios méxico guatemala y
honduras han reforzado sus controles
fronterizos porque temen que los
pandilleros huyan hacia su territorio
nuestro corresponsal en guatemala'
andrés suárez jaramillo no es amplia
con sobrevuelos y amplios dispositivos
policiales los países de centroamérica
blindan sus fronteras ante una posible
diáspora de pandilleros salvadoreños
conocidos como mareros por el cerco que
el presidente nayib ukulele se está
imponiendo en su denominada guerra
contra las pandillas en mexico por
ejemplo en especial en el estado de
chiapas hay preocupación por el que
apodan un efecto cucaracha en el cual
los pandilleros de las temidas bandas
criminales mara salvatrucha y barrio 18
escapen del estado de excepción con
rumbo hacia el norte del continente aquí
en guatemala la prensa local titula
operativo contra maderos salvadoreños se
trata de intensos patrullajes las 24
horas en los pasos fronterizos de
guatemala con el salvador y honduras así
como de requisas en las cárceles
guatemaltecas donde se presume que los
mareros encarcelados estarían
comunicando con los pandilleros recién
llegados este fortalecimiento de las
medidas fronterizas fue tomada por el
ministro de gobernación de guatemala
david napoleón y tardará un mes mismo
tiempo que el estado de excepción en el
salvado también para tranquilizar a los
guatemaltecos y a los turistas en
tiempos de celebración de semana santa
sin embargo recordemos que tanto el
salvador guatemala como honduras
pertenecen al convenio de libre
movilidad sea 4 por el cual los
salvadoreños pueden cruzar fronteras sin
presentar pasaporte ni los trámites
engorrosos de migración lo cual le
facilitaría a los pandilleros atravesar
hacia otros países sin lugar a ser
detectados la corte penal internacional
abrirá una oficina en venezuela en el
marco de una investigación por presuntos
crímenes de lesa humanidad cometidos en
el país la noticia se conoció en una
visita no anunciada con anterioridad del
fiscal de la cpi karim camps al país el
fiscal compareció junto a nicolás maduro
ante la televisión pública venezolana
para comunicar los avances en la
relación entre el órgano judicial y
venezuela- nuestra corresponsal en el
país daniela zambrano tiene los detalles
ha dicho el fiscal de la corte penal
internacional karim khan que este es un
paso importante para poder cumplir con
las obligaciones establecidas en el
estatuto de roma la apertura de esta
oficina en caracas sería un hecho aunque
no se ha hablado de fechas aún el
anuncio lo hizo el fiscal de la corte
penal internacional desde el palacio de
miraflores junto a nicolás maduró y dijo
que otro de los acuerdos fue que se
otorgarán visados múltiples para
facilitar el acceso del grupo de trabajo
de la corte penal internacional a
venezuela sin tanta burocracia también
se acordó que a mediados de 2023 se
realice una reunión de alto nivel para
intercambiar opiniones sobre el estatuto
del estatuto de roma y la justicia
internacional nicolás maduro ha dicho
que han sido tres días de trabajo esta
es una visita que no puede anunciar a
los medios de comunicación recordemos
que a finales de 2020 la corte penal
internacional anunció que abriría una
investigación contra venezuela' por
delitos de lesa humanidad y fue en
noviembre del año 2021 cuando el propio
fiscal karim khan en una visita al
palacio de miraflores
anuncio que se avanzaba a la segunda
fase y empieza para los musulmanes el
mes sagrado del ramadán este año marcado
por las complicaciones generadas por el
aumento de los precios la luna nueva
marca el inicio del mes de ayuno que
coincide con la fecha en la que ala
comenzó a revelarle el corán el libro
sagrado del islám al profeta mahoma
según la creencia musulmana
hasta aquí este repaso a la actualidad
internacional sigan con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]